you know I just keep coming back to the
fact that he couldn't think of a better
safer than stop black mirror time once
again and before I get into it a little
bit on the day this goes out it's my
birthday I'm turning 25 for the 12th
time I'm old but yes happy birthday to
me
I mentioned this once before I'm not
gonna continue to plug it overly but the
link will always be or the information
will always be down below but I'll put
it up in the screen to stop um if you
feel like sending me something um I have
a p.o box now there it is this sounds
like a really desperate plea like please
please come to my party and validate my
existence I'm not throwing a party that
I'm inviting everybody I got okay
off this topic call me another trip
around the Sun and I didn't die so play
test because it's Wednesday which means
black mirror and I went into this one
nervous not for the reasons I went into
things like metal head or the Waldo
moment somewhat nervous where those sort
of had lower ratings you know on IMDB
and things like that but rather because
I just based off the title I knew this
was gonna deal with video games and well
honestly anything that claims to be
about cutting edge or near future
technology has a tendency to be fairly
embarrassing into age poorly no matter
what and Barger has done pretty well
getting around that but things that deal
specifically with video games tend to
age of the worst of any of this sort of
thing so yeah I was who was really
nervous when it started being like is
this is this just gonna be cringy
because you know when you see anything
that's that's dealing with ooh look at
this high-end video game it alway it
almost always looks like crabs like
that's not how games work that's not
what people like about games it either
depicts like just junk and claims oh
it's the hot new game or in
like it does stuff that is antithetical
to what gaming is and was obviously
written by someone who has never played
an actual video game any more recent
than Donkey Kong but thankfully not the
case here now I will say in terms of
video games survival horror is not
really my bag I appreciate it I
certainly appreciate how effective it
can be at times but I'm not I'm not big
into just being scared like in general
that's kind of not really my thing
I do enjoy horror movies from time to
time but being scared by them is not
something that I particularly enjoy
about it that said I did enjoy this
episode this probably the most
straightforward episode that black
mirror has given us in terms of not only
how it unfolds but just being very
upfront right off the bat with this is
what it's going to be like you know just
poke just signposting you know
augmented reality don't trust your eyes
we're gonna be messing with your head
while the characters head and
theoretically the audience's head as
well and considering how upfront they
were about all that pulled it off pretty
well I think in a funny way
going with almost a stereotypical
American who talks too much and sort of
makes awkward jokes then small talk that
doesn't quite work kind of thing you
know which I I get I guess sometimes
watching you know British entertainment
when they when they depict Americans
tend to be that tends to be that kind of
thing I can't say that it's wrong but it
does feel a little bit like ah that's
how that's how the rest of the world
sees us isn't it but I think it really
worked in this case because I think for
what he's going through you want a
character who talks too much you want a
character where it makes sense that
they're just gonna keep talking through
everything that's going on because
otherwise you know that becomes a bit of
a why are you narrating your actions but
if you establish it a bit of he tends to
fill the silence and just keep talking
then yeah then it works so that played
out pretty well I think the biggest sort
of empathy point for me
was him talking about his father and the
way he lost his father I'll touch on
this briefly but that's kind of a
messing with your head or tends to hit
me harder than ghosts demons what have
you so like American Horror Story the
the season that hit me the hardest was
the second one Asylum most people I know
like the first season best which was
later dubbed Murder House but for me the
reason Asylum hit me harder is not being
able to trust your own mind is something
that really fundamentally terrifies me
and I did really identify with Cooper
because he talked about his father and
how he lost him and in my case it was my
grandfather who had dementia I was very
fortunate he didn't have he didn't have
Alzheimer's it wasn't his long-term
memory that what he knew who everybody
was but he didn't know what day of the
week it was he didn't know what time it
was he didn't know if he had eaten lunch
that day and you know to watch that
happen over time was was not a
particularly pleasant experience and it
is sort of my own great fear as I get as
I get older that I will lose my mind so
this does it doesn't it does tap into
that fear a little bit it doesn't like
really drill into it but this is one of
those cases where there have been some
of the soda Blackmore I've said I like
it I see what it's doing but it doesn't
quite hit me as hard as it might for
other people because I don't connect to
it in X way so like with Archangel I
that probably would have connected with
me more if I had a teenager I don't
I have a kid much younger than that and
maybe once I've had the experience of my
kid being a teenager maybe I'll identify
with that one more but I still could
recognize that you know if that you know
hit you on that level that episode
probably worked better for you and I
think this is this is a little bit of
that with play tests but with something
that is impacts me that might not have
that connection for everybody else and
as a result I might actually like this
episode of
better than other people but I mean
coming back to what I said before it is
it is very straightforward it's I mean
it does kinda has twists to it but there
the twist that you're expecting based
off the premise the you know pushing the
envelope of is it real is it fake is he
still in the game you know how is it
messing with him and the just the way
that it pushes on that is it's
well-executed it's not exactly shocking
because like is that it's kind of part
and parcel for the style of story that
it's telling I dare it there's a lot of
really great moments in it though I've
looked I loved that you know he opens up
the cupboard and he's looking for snacks
he finds something and he's he's about
to go to cover it he just pause and the
shots framed so that like his head's way
over here and here's the here's the
cupboard door so it was like it's here
the camera focuses right here and anyone
who's seen any number of horror movies
knows okay as soon as he closes that
there's something right there and he's
holding that door going as soon as I
closes he's gonna be right there I know
he is and that just again that connected
me with him as a character all the
better like he knows the cliches he's
not dumb so you know he closes he sees a
shadow like I see there you go but then
it moves in something that does not
match the shadow we just saw comes
around the corner it's like whoa okay
yeah that's a legitimate reason to be
spooked even though you saw it coming so
that worked really well
I love then there's no way this was by
accident I love when he's trying to find
the exit point in the house would you
kindly open the door and he wanted for
the game where in the last couple
generations Bioshock would you kindly
yes that was that was a smart Easter Egg
hats off to that one oh yeah yes so that
all that what that was another one like
there was obviously I don't know if
Charlie Brooker himself is a gamer but
at the very least he got the input of
gamers when figuring out how to write
this this
feels like something and someone who
surely games would come up with and
especially when it comes to you know the
more horror tinged elements of things
it is tapping into what you know
psychological horror games try to tap
into because I mean when you when you
pop in a horror game
I'm much like when you watch our movie
you are on your guard to a certain
extent you are expecting for it to try
and scare you and it has to find ways
around that to unnerve you even though
it knows you're expecting stuff so and
and all that is is played out really
well I liked Katie who was the voice in
his ear just as a personality I enjoyed
her I enjoyed you know that I'm talking
back and forth it was a cool dynamic and
and the lead-up stuff initially I
thought this felt a little protracted a
little dragged out but I think I think
it was important that we understood him
as a character as well as we did in
order to in order for you know what he
went through to not just be a series of
jump scares for it to be we understood
you know even if you didn't necessarily
empathize with him as the character I'm
really connect with him at the very
least you understood based of what
you've seen before why what was
happening to him was hitting him as hard
as it was and it just starts with a
basic surface level scare of a spider
okay guy doesn't like spiders but then
it ups it more with the bully that we
heard and talked about and then you knew
ultimately it was gonna drill down to
his parents and probably his mom and
fittingly enough it does and that's
where it ends and I do think it's also a
neat touch that the whole thing is for
hundredths of a second is how long
before it broke him and man the the
speed of the human mind so yeah yeah I
enjoyed it it's funny I actually liked
it more now as I talk it out because
when at first and I was like it was
pretty good but it did seem a little too
straightforward you know versus what I'm
used to from Black Mirror but it's
this one's a good one I mean they're all
good they'd like even the most
questionable like I don't know about
that episodes of black bear are still
better than whole lot of what else is on
TV but that's play test did you see it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do support me on
patreon like subscribe follow me on
Twitter send me stuff to my p.o box
links for all that stuff or the address
in the case of the PIO box are down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]